this is gonna be a new era for the
morning show 8 seconds to you
[Music]
to her good morning I'm bringing you
some sad and upsetting news and while I
don't know the details of the
allegations she's throwing me under the
bus
Mitch Kessler my co-host and partner of
15 years was fired today we are facing
the biggest crisis in our history life
just ended for no good reason we're in
the middle of an epic rebirth her
sell-by date expired years ago I want
you to start filming some new people
I don't fit the mold what mold is that
any mold really your show sucks thank
you it's news I want wardrobe pest
screen test makeup test we need a
contract
where's legally already most people want
to trust that the person that is telling
them about the world is an honest person
[Music]
like you yes
[Music]
your words spoke to America people are
know to say they want are watching a
beloved woman's rake down is timeless
American entertainment I just need to be
able to control the narrative so that
I'm not written out of it you stole my
life
you left me in the woods with a pack of
wolves you just think I'm gonna do this
this chair could be yours I don't want
your job
Oh
[Music]
you walk out that door you are never
gonna get back in the part you guys
never seem to realize is that you don't
have the power anymore and frankly I've
let you bozos handle this long enough we
are doing this my way
[Music]
what happened to your TV we had a
disagreement
[Music]
you